No Nonsense tough as Nails fiercely
optimistic Sharon Leone is a lot of
things and so is the woman who plays the
division 1501 Chief Diane Farr heck fire
country isn't even the first time she's
played a firefighter the television
series and happily ever after is best
remembered as a trashy comedy in the
vein of Married With Children but with
the unusual edition of a smoking boozing
raunchy stuffed bunny called Mr floppy
the series kick-started The careers of
Nikki Cox Kevin Connolly and Justin
burfield we've got the show also marked
by unfaz television debut in the small
role of Michelle she plays a Parisian in
the future who is listening to Pierre
read life in the Toy Bin a book written
by Mr floppy 30 years ago as the board
wine drinking Parisian she tells Pierre
about the rumor she heard that floppy
was an American her total time on screen
is about two minutes and ends after she
and Pierre think they've seen Mickey
walk in the distance and quickly run off
to follow him yeah it was that kind of
show in C season 4 of The Drew Carey
Show far took on the role of Tracy a
woman who captures a romantic interests
of Drew Oswald and Lewis with none of
them realizing they're dating the same
woman Lewis meets Tracy first at a
science fiction convention where they're
both cosplaying as aliens and he asks
her out on a date for Friday night the
following day Oswald delivers Tracy a
package and asks her out for Saturday
later in the day she ends up in Drew's
office and he asks her out for Sunday
after the men realized her while dating
the same woman Tracy agrees to keep
dating them as long as they don't fight
over her eventually she chooses Lewis to
go to her sister's wedding signifying
that they're now in a relationship after
three episodes we never see Tracy again
from 2001 through 2002 dianfar played
Detective Jan fendrick in the Dennis
Leary and Peter toland creative police
drama the job when that series was
canceled she got on board for the Duo's
next drama rescue me as the blunt and
directs firefighter Laura miles she
struggles when she joins a firehouse and
clashes with everyone after falling in
love with another firefighter she starts
to question her presence there
constantly feeling like she's always
passed over because she's a girl in the
season 2 finale we find out exactly how
frustrated Laura is with being the only
woman in the firehouse after the chief
refuses to let her climb down to rescue
a child in a burning building because
she's a girl she transfers else and
disappears in reality far left because
she wanted to go back to LA and the job
and rescue me had kept her in New York
for five years upon leaving she told
Entertainment Weekly that she was close
to Dennis Leary despite her departure
from the show oh what's the matter
next up for dianfar was a character of
FBI psychologist Megan Reeves on numbers
co-starring alongside Rob Morrow and
David krumholz in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly she said the
following about her character Megan is a
bit of a cowboy she has a master's
degree comes from money and wears a
fantastic suit but still likes carrying
a gun it's high-end adrenaline her
character serves as a replacement
beginning in the season 2 premiere after
profiler Terry Lake left in the season
one finale to move back to Washington DC
fast start as Megan for three seasons
helping the team with her profiles of
their suspects during that time Megan
also started a relationship with Dr
Larry fleinhardt which far admitted she
spoke to the producers about she
explained how she believed they had eyed
her to serve in Another Love Triangle
but she wanted the opportunity to have a
storyline with Peter McNichol whom she
thought would Elevate her as a performer
in 2009 dianfar took the role of Jill
Robinson on season 3 of Californication
Jill is a writer and a teaching
assistant for Professor Richard Bates
when fans meet Jill she is trying to
earn her PhD in English literature and
upon meeting Hank Moody she wants him to
stay away from her of course this just
makes Hank all the more interested while
she tells him that he irritates her it's
only a matter of time before they start
casually sleeping together when she
joined the series fard recently had
three children four more than two years
of each other feeling nervous about
showing her body on a show in which
nudity occurs as often as talking she
had a stipulation telling the Chicago
Tribune when I was offered a role on
Californication as David duchovny's new
love interest I accepted only if the
producers would profit me a body double
after Becca's mom and hangs on enough
again love interests Karen returns from
New York and suggests the three reunite
and move to New York together he begins
attempting to break it off with all the
women he's been seeing including Jill
Jill tries to make the relationship last
longer telling hang that she accepts him
for who he is but Hank is unmoved the
2010 saw Diane Farr appear in a lot of
guest roles including appearances on
shows like private practice
Secret Life of the American Teenager and
blackish in 2018 she starred as Maya in
splitting up together alongside Jenna
Fisher and Oliver Hudson the series is
about a married couple Lena and Martin
who decide to get divorced but still
plan to live together with the duo
taking alternating turns living in the
house and the garage Maya is Lena's
outspoken sister who wants Lena to get
back into enjoying the world of being
single while critics panned the show
there was a lot of love for far and her
character with Pace magazine suggesting
more Maya as a fix to improve the series
by season two Maya found out she was
pregnant and decided she was going to be
a single mother unfortunately we'll
never know how that went as the show was
canceled after two seasons
foreign